all right
thank you
thank you so much Thank You president
rife Thank You class of 1966 that was
that was alarming walking along and
seeing 66 and then somebody saying oh
it's their 50th I just I almost had a
heart attack time time flies and mostly
thank you to the class of 2016 it is
such an honor to be part of your day
it's an honor to be here with you with
your friends your professors and your
parents but let's be honest this is an
honor I didn't really earn I'm just
going to put that out there I mean I've
seen the list of previous commencement
speakers Nobel Prize winners the UN
secretary-general president of the World
Bank president of the United States and
who did you get the guy who did the
voice for a cartoon horse
if you're wondering which cartoon horse
that spirit stallion of the Cimarron a
movie some of you might have grown up
watching it's definitely one of my best
performances as a cartoon horse well
look I don't even have a college degree
as you might have heard I went to
Harvard I just didn't graduate from
Harvard I got pretty close but I started
to get movie roles and I didn't finish
all my courses but I put on a cap and
gown and I walked with my class my mom
and dad and brother were there and
everything I just never got an actual
degree you could say I kind of faked
graduated so you can imagine how excited
I was when president rife called to
invite me to speak at the MIT
commencement and then you can imagine
how sorry I was to learn that the MIT
commencement speaker does not get to go
home with a degree so yes for the second
time in my life I am fake graduating
from a college in my hometown and my mom
and my dad and my brother are here again
and this time I brought my wife and my
four kids so welcome kids to your dad's
second fake graduation you must be so
proud so as I said my mom is here she's
a professor so she knows the value of an
MIT degree she also knows that I
couldn't have gotten in here I mean
Harvard but you know barely or a safety
school like Yale look I'm not running
for any kind of office I can say pretty
much whatever I want
no I couldn't have gotten in here but I
did grow up here I grew up in the
neighborhood in the shadow of this
imposing place my brother Kyle and I and
my friend Ben Affleck brilliant guy good
guy never really amounted to much we all
grew up right here in Central Square
children of this sometimes rocky
marriage between this city and its great
institutions to us MIT was kind of like
the man this big impressive impersonal
force at least that was our provincial
knee-jerk teenage reaction anyway and
then Ben and I shot a movie here now one
of the scenes in Good Will Hunting was
based on something that actually
happened to my brother Kyle he was
visiting a physicist that we knew at MIT
and he was walking down the infinite
corridor he saw those blackboards that
lie in the halls and so my brother who's
an artist picked up some chalk and wrote
an incredibly elaborate totally fake
version of an equation and it was so
cool and completely insane that no one
erased it for months this is a true
story anyway Kyle came back and he said
you guys listen to this
they've got black boards running down
the hall because these kids are so smart
they just need to you know drop
everything and solve problems it was
then we knew for sure we could never
have gotten in but like I said we later
made a movie here which did not go
unnoticed on campus in fact I'd like to
read you some actual lines some selected
passages from the review of Good Will
Hunting in the MIT school paper if you
haven't seen it will was me and Sean is
played by the late Robin Williams a man
I miss a hell of a lot so I'm quoting
here Good Will Hunting is very
entertaining but then again any movie
partially said at MIT has to be but
there's more in the end the reviewer
writes the actual character development
flies out the window Will and Shawn talk
bond solve each other's problems and
then cry and hug each other after said
crying and hugging the movie ends
such feel-good pretentiousness is
definitely not my mug of eggnog well
that kind of hurts but don't worry I
know now better than to cry at MIT but
look I'm happy to be here anyway I might
still be a knee-jerk teenager in key
respects but I know an amazing school
when I see it we're lucky to have MIT in
Boston and we're lucky it draws the
people that it does people like you from
around the world I mean you're working
on some crazy stuff in these buildings
stuff that would freak me out if I
actually understood it theories models
paradigm shifts I'm going to tell you
about one that's been on my mind
simulation theory most of you probably
heard of this maybe even took a class
with Max tegmark but for the uninitiated
there's a philosopher named Nick Bostrom
at Oxford and he's postulated if there's
a truly advanced form of intelligence
out there in the universe it's probably
advanced enough to run simulations of
entire worlds maybe trillions of them
maybe even our own so the basic idea as
I understand it is that we could be
living in a massive simulation run by a
far smarter similar civilization like a
giant computer game and we don't even
know it and here's the thing a lot of
physicists a lot of cosmologists they
won't rule it out I just watched a
discussion online a few weeks back it
was moderated by Neil deGrasse Tyson of
the Hayden Planetarium and by and large
the panel couldn't and wouldn't give a
definitive answer
Tyson himself put the odds of 50/50 now
I'm not sure how scientific that was but
it had numbers in it so I was impressed
but it it got me to thinking what if
this all of this is a simulation I mean
it's a crazy idea but what if it is and
if there are multiple simulations how
come we have to be in the one where
Donald Trump becomes the Republican
nominee for president
can we like transfer to a different one
well professor tegmark has an excellent
take on all of this my advice he said
recently is to go out and do really
interesting things so the simulators
don't shut you down now then again what
if it isn't a simulation either way my
answer is the same either way what we do
matters what we do affects the outcome
so either way MIT you've got to go out
and do really interesting things
important things inventive things
because this world real or imagined this
world has some problems that we need you
to drop everything and solve so go ahead
take your pick from the world's worst
buffet economic inequality that's a
problem how about the refugee crisis
massive global insecurity climate change
pandemics institutional racism Appleton
nativism fear driven brains working
overtime here in America and in places
like Austria where a far-right candidate
nearly won the President presidential
election for the first time since World
War two or the brexit for God's sakes
that insane idea that the best path for
Britain is to cut loose from Europe and
drift out to sea I mean what is Europe
even going to look like in 25 years and
add to that an American political system
that's failing we've got congressmen on
a two-year election cycle who are
incentivized to think short-term and
simply do not engage with long term
problems and add to that a media that
thrives on scandal and people with their
pants down anything to get you to tune
in so they can hock you products that
you don't need and add to that a banking
system that steals people's money it's
all right I'm not running for office
but by the way while I'm on this let me
just say to this to the bankers
specifically the ones who brought you
the biggest heist in history it was
theft and you knew it it was fraud and
you knew it and you know what else we
know that you knew it
so yeah you sort of got away with it you
got that house in the Hamptons that
other people paid for is their own
mortgages went underwater and you might
have their money but you don't have our
respect and just so you know when we
pass you on the street and look you in
the eye that's what we're thinking and I
don't know if justice is coming for you
in this life or the next
but if justice does come for you in this
life her name will be Elizabeth Warren
alright so before my little banking
digression I rattled off a bunch of big
problems and a natural response is to
tune out and turn away but before you
step out into our big troubled world I
want to pass along a piece of advice
that Bill Clinton offered me a little
over a decade ago actually when he said
it it felt less like advice and more
like a direct order but what he said was
turned toward the problems you see you
have to engage and turn towards the
problems that you see except it sounded
like turn towards the problem that you
see
but when he said this to me he literally
turned his body for emphasis towards me
yeah no listen it seemed kind of simple
at the time but the older I get the more
wisdom I see in this that is what I want
to urge you to do today to turn towards
the problems that you see and engage
with them walk right up to him look him
in the eye and then look yourself in the
eye and decide what you're going to do
about them now in my experience there is
just no substitute for actually going
and seeing these things I owe this
insight like many others to my mom when
I was a teenager mom thought it was
important for us to see the world
outside of Boston and I don't just mean
Framingham she took us to places like
Guatemala where we saw extreme poverty
up close and it changed my whole frame
of reference and I think it was that
same impulse that took my brother and me
to Zambia in 2006 as part of the one
campaign the organization that bono
founded to fight desperate and what he
calls stupid poverty and preventable
disease in the developing world and on
that trip in a small community I met
this girl and I walked with her to a
nearby borewell where she could get
clean water she'd just come home from
school and I knew the reason that she
was able to go go to school at all was
clean water namely the fact that it was
available nearby so she didn't have to
walk miles back and forth all day to get
water for her family like so many girls
and women do around the world so I asked
her if she wanted to stay in her village
when she grew up and she smiled and said
no no I want to go to Lusaka and become
a nurse so clean water something as
basic as that had given this child a
chance to dream and as I learned more
about water and sanitation I was floored
by the extent to which it undergirds all
these problems of extreme poverty the
fate of entire communities economies
countries is caught up in that glass of
water something the rest of us get to
take for granted people at one told me
that water is the least sexy and cool
aspect of the effort to fight extreme
poverty and water goes hand in hand with
sanitation so if you think water isn't
sexy you should try to get into the [ __ ]
business but I was hooked already I the
enormity of it the complexity of the
issue it just it just hooked me
and getting out in the world and meeting
people like this little girl is what put
me on the path to starting water.org
with a brilliant civil engineer named
Gary white and for Gary and me seeing
the world and its problems its
possibilities heightened our disbelief
that so many people millions 660 million
in fact can't get a safe clean drink of
water or a clean private place to go to
the bathroom there are more people with
a cell phone than access to a toilet on
our planet and this heightened our
determination to do something about it
now you see some tough things out there
but you also see life-changing joy and
it all changes you there was a refugee
crisis back in oh nine that I read about
in this amazing article in The New York
Times people were streaming across the
border of Zimbabwe to a little little
town in northern South Africa called
Messina while I was working in South
Africa at the time so I went up to
Messina to see for myself what was going
on I spent a day speaking with women who
had made this perilous journey across
the Limpopo River dodging bandits on one
side crocodiles in the river bandits on
the other every woman that I spoke to
that day had been raped every single one
on one side of the river or both and at
the end of my time there I met a woman
who was so positive she was so joyful
she had just been given her papers so
she'd been granted political asylum in
South Africa and in the midst of this
joyful conversation I mustered up my
courage and I said ma'am do you mind my
asking were you assaulted on your
journey to South Africa and she replied
still smiling oh yes I was raped but I
have my papers now and those bastards
didn't get my dignity
human beings will take your breath away
they will teach you so much
but you have to engage I only had that
experience because I went there myself
it was difficult in many ways but of
course that's the point there is a lot
of trouble out there MIT but there's a
lot of beauty too and I hope you see
both but again the point is not to
become some kind of well-rounded
high-minded voyeur the point is to
eliminate your blind spots the things
that keep us from grasping the bigger
picture and look even though I grew up
in this neighborhood in this incredible
multicultural neighborhood that was a
little rough at that time I find myself
here before you as a middle-aged
American white male movie star I don't
have a clue where my blind spots begin
and end but looking at the world as it
is and engaging with it is the first
step towards identifying our blind spots
and that's when we can really start to
understand ourselves better and begin to
solve some problems and with that as
your goal there's a few more things I
hope you'll keep in mind first you're
going to fail sometimes and that's a
good thing for all the amazing successes
I've been lucky to share and few things
have shaped me more than the auditions
that Ben and I used to go on as young
actors where we'd get on a bus we'd show
up in New York we'd wait our turn we'd
cry our hearts out for a scene and then
be told okay thanks meaning game over we
used to call it being okay thanks and
those experiences became our armor all
right now you're thinking great thanks
Matt failure is good and thanks a ton
tell me something I didn't hear at my
high school graduation to which I say
okay I will you know the real danger for
MIT graduates it's not getting okay
thanks to the real danger is all that
smoke that's been blown up your
graduation gowns about how freakin smart
you are well you are that smart but
don't believe the hype that's thrown at
you you don't have all the answers and
you shouldn't and that's fine you're
going to have your share of bad ideas
for one are for me one was playing a
character named Edgar
wacker I wish I could tell you I'm
making that up that's but as the great
philosopher Benjamin a slack once said
judge me by how good my good ideas are
not how bad my bad ideas are you've got
a suit up in your Armour you've got to
get ready to sound like a total fool not
having an answer isn't embarrassing it's
an opportunity don't be afraid to ask
questions I know so much less the second
time I'm fake graduating than the first
time the second thing I want to leave
you with is you got to keep listening
the world wants to hear your idea is
good and bad but today is not the day
you switch from receive to transmit once
you do that your education is over and
your education should never be over even
outside of your work there are always
ways to keep challenging yourself listen
to online lectures I just took a retook
a philosophy course that I took at
Harvard when I was 19 you go to MIT
OpenCourseWare go to wait but why
dot-com go to ted.com I'm told there's
even a Trump University I have no
earthly idea what they teach there but
whatever you do just keep listening even
to people you don't agree with at all I
love what President Obama said at Howard
University's commencement last month he
said democracy requires compromise even
when you are 100 percent right I heard
that and thought here is a man who has
been happily married for a long time not
that the first lady has ever been wrong
about anything just like my wife never
wrong not even when she decided last
month it in a family with four kids what
was missing in our lives was a third
rescue dog that was an outstanding
decision honey
I love you the third and last thought I
want to leave you with is that not every
problem has a high tech solution now if
anybody has the right to think we can
pretty much tech support the world's
problems into submission its you think
of the innovations that got their start
at MIT or by MIT alums the world wide
web nuclear fission
condensed soup that's true you should be
very proud of that
but the truth is we can't science the
you-know-what out of every problem there
is not always an app for that I mean
take water again as an example people
are always looking at some quite
scientific quick fix for the problem of
dirty and disease-ridden water a pill
you put in a glass of filter etc but
there's no magic bullet the problem is
just too complex yes there is definitely
absolutely a role for science there's
incredible advances being made in clean
water technology companies and
universities are getting in on the game
and I'm glad to know that professors
like Susan Merck out at D lab are
focusing on water and sanitation but as
I'm sure she'd agree science alone can't
solve this problem we need to be just as
innovative in public policy just as
innovative in our financial models and
that's the idea behind approach an
approach we have at water credit at
water or called water credit it's based
on Gary's insight that poor people we're
already paying for their water and they
know less than the rest of us want to
participate in their own solutions
so water credit helps connect the poor
with microfinance organizations which
enables them to build water connections
and toilets in their homes and
communities and this approach is really
working helping four million people so
far and it's only the start our loans
are paying back at ninety nine percent
and above which is a hell of a better
deal in those bankers I was talking
about earlier gave anybody and I agree
it is still not sexy but it is without a
doubt the coolest thing I have ever been
a part of so thanks
so let me ask you this in closing what
are you going to be a part of what is
the problem that you will try to solve
whatever your answer it is not going to
be easy
sometimes your work will hit a dead end
sometimes your work will be measured in
half steps sometimes your work will make
you wear a white sequined military
uniform and make love to Michael Douglas
alright maybe that's just my work but
for all of you here your work starts
today and seriously how lucky are you I
mean what are the odds that you are the
ones who are here today in the Earth's
4.5 billion year run with a hundred
billion people who have lived and died
and the seven billion of us here now
here you are yes here you are alive at a
time of potential extinction level
events a time when fewer and fewer
people can cause more and more damage a
time when science and technology may not
hold all the answers but are
indispensable to any solution what are
the odds that you get to be you right
now the MIT class of 2016 with so much
on the line there are potentially
trillions of human beings who will
someday exist or not whose fate in large
part depends on the choices you make on
your ideas on your grit and persistence
and willingness to engage if this were a
movie I was trying to pitch I'd be
laughed out of every office in Hollywood
Joseph Campbell himself would tell me to
throttle down and lower the stakes but I
can't because this is a fact this is not
fiction this improbable thing is
actually happening there is more at
stake today than in any story ever told
and how lucky you are that you're here
and you're you and how lucky we are that
you're here and you are you so I hope
you'll turn toward the problem of your
choosing
I hope you'll turn toward the problem of
your choosing I hope you'll drop
everything and I hope you'll solve it
this is your life class of 2016 this is
your moment and it is all down to you
ready player one your game begins now
thank you congratulations